I just think about those reports that
came out years ago about those dental
chairs or like torture type chairs that
were in these apartments of his in like
weird places and weird rooms and who's
cleaning up this place who's not who
who's not reporting all this weird
activity of these children uh so I'm I'm
looking forward to it coming out but I'm
also not going to be surprised when
people look at it and spin it to support
whatever narrative they want to sell so
they see Trump they're going to go with
the Trump angle you see Clinton they're
going go with the Clinton angle and it's
going to become like this everyone's
going to be on it every name will be
attached but Trump's in it and the media
is going to go nuts and be like Trump
listed in Epstein documents anybody that
can anyone that's you know from the
right that is on the list is going to be
the focus from the mainstream media if
they talk about it I do think the
mainstream media wants this to you know
quiet down and go away um overall I
think it's bad for the establishment
because everyone knows that Jeffrey
Epstein was was involved with a lot of
people look the guy was a a master
networker